all right we're gonna get started this
is the last lecture for the term I just
a few logistics things when we're
getting at the beginning so just a
friendly reminder
project write-up is due on the 20th at
11:59 p.m. there are no late days and
then the poster presentations are on
Friday at 8:30 a.m. you need to submit
your poster as well and that should be
submitted online to a grade scope by the
same time we'll open up a submission for
that in advance and there's also no late
days for that you should have received
an email with some details about the
poster session any questions reach out
to us so we have any questions right now
it's the last week of office hours we
won't have office hours next week finals
week for most people but you can reach
out to us on Piazza or if you have extra
questions you know we're happy to find a
time okay all right so what we're gonna
do today is so last time of course just
the quiz and we're gonna be sending out
our goal is to send out grades for
everybody that took it on Monday to send
them out today we're almost done grading
those and for that there are a few
people who are still taking it late so
though we have to grade the scpd's but
everybody else should get their quiz
scores who took it Monday should get it
back today and then today what we're
gonna do is we're gonna talk just a
little bit about Monte Carlo tree search
as well as discuss them and of course
stuff so why Monte Carlo tree search um
who hears heard of alphago all right yes
so I mean alphago you could argue is one
of the major AI achievements of the last
you know 10 to 20 years and it really
has been a spectacular achievement that
was achieved much faster than was
anticipated yeah to beat humans on the
board game go which is considered an
extremely hard game so the Monte Carlo
tree search was a critical part of you
know to achieve a success plus a lot of
other additional things but it's one of
the aspects that we have not talked
about very much so far in class so I
think talking about Monte Carlo tree
search so you're familiar with some of
the ideas behind that and therefore some
of the ideas behind alphago are useful
to be aware of and then also because
when we start to think about Monte Carlo
tree search it's a way for us to think
about model-based reinforcement learning
which is a very powerful tool that we
haven't talked about as much in part
because we haven't seen as much success
in the deep learning case with models
and I'm happy to talk tomorrow about
that you did today or offline but I
think that going forward it's likely to
be a really productive Avenue of
research and we can talk about why that
might be particularly useful in alpha in
alphago so what we're gonna do first is
we're gonna sort of talk a little bit
again about sort of model-based
reinforcement learning and then we'll
talk about simulation simulation based
search which is where Monte Carlo tree
search comes up Ashley just because
everyone takes different classes and I'm
curious who here has covered Monte Carlo
tree search you know in another class
okay just to what class was it
yeah yeah which is generally Oh general
game thing would be a good one to come
bring it in okay oh and also just think
it's people are interested at the end
I'll also mention some other classes
where you can learn more about
reinforcement learning
alright so mobile based reinforcement
learning most of what we've talked about
this term though not all of it but most
of what we've talked about this term
particularly when we're talking about
learning which means we don't know how
the world works is that we're thinking
about either learning a policy or a
value function or both directly from
data and what we're gonna talk about
more today is talking about learning a
specific model so just to remind
ourselves cuz it has been a little while
yet we're gonna be talking about
learning the transition and/or reward
model and we talked about this a little
bit maybe I don't know a number a few
weeks ago I came up also an exploration
but once you have a model you can use
planning with that and just to refresh
our memories planning is where we take a
known model of the world and then we use
value iteration or policy iteration or
dynamic programming in general to try to
compute a policy for those given models
in contrast to that of course we've
talked a lot about model free RL where
there's no model we just directly learn
a value function from experience and now
we are going to learn a model from
experience and then plan using that now
the planning that we do in addition to
sort of the approaches that are known
from classical decision like dynamic
programming also can be any of the other
techniques that we've talked about so
far in class so you know once we have
this this is a disconnect as a simulator
and so once you have that you can do
model free RL using that simulator or
you can do policy search or anything
else you would like to do given that you
have a model of the world basically just
acts as a simulator you can use it to
generate experience as well as do things
like dynamic programming
you can do search all of those things so
once you have a simulator to the world
that's great the downside of course can
be if that simulator is not very good
what does that do in terms of the
resulting estimates okay so just to
think of it again we have our world it's
generating actions and rewards and
States and now we're gonna think about
sort of explicitly trying to model those
so and a lot of cases you may know the
reward function not always been a lot of
practical applications you'll know the
reward function so if you're designing
like a reinforcement learning based
system for something like customer
service you probably have a reward
function in mind like engagement or
purchases or things like that you may
not have a very good model of the
customer so there are a lot of practical
examples where you'll need to learn the
dynamics model either implicitly or
explicitly but the reward function
itself might be known all right so how
do we think about this in terms of a
loop we think about having some
experience so this could be things like
you know state action reward next state
tuples that we then feed into a model
and this is going to output either a
reward or a transition model we do
planning with that which can be dynamic
programming or cue learning or many of
the other techniques we've seen here
policy search and then that has to give
us a way to pick an action so that has
to give us an action that we can then
use over here we don't have to
necessarily compute a full value
function all we need to know is what is
the next action to take we're gonna
exploit that when we get to Monte Carlo
tree search that we don't necessarily
have to compute a full value function
for the world nor do we have to have a
complete policy all we have to know is
what should we do for this particular
action next so some of the advantages
about this is we there are a lot of
supervised learning methods including
from deep deep learning which we can use
to learn models some of them are better
or worse super suited so our transition
dynamics were generally going to think
of a stochastic so we're gonna need
supervised learning method
that can predict distributions for
reward models we can often treat them as
scalars so then we can use very classic
regression based approaches and the the
other nice thing about model versus
reinforcement learning is like what we
talked about for exploration that we can
often have explicit models over our
uncertainty of how good are our models
and once we have uncertainty over our
models of the world we can use that to
propagate into uncertainty over the
decisions we make so in the bandit case
that was pretty direct because in the
bandit case so for bandits we had
uncertainty of the reward of an arm and
that just directly represented our
uncertainty over the value because it
was only a single time step in the case
of MDPs
we could represent uncertainty over the
the the reward and the dynamics model
informs of these sort of bonuses and
then propagate that information during
planning and that again allowed us to
think about sort of how well do we know
the value of different states and
actions and what could it be what should
it be optimistically
now the downsides is that you know first
we're going to learn the model and then
we're going to construct a value
function and there could be two sources
of approximation error there because
we're gonna get an approximate model and
then we're going to do approximate
planning in general for a large state
spaces and so we can get compounding
errors in that case now another place
that we saw compounding errors earlier
in this course was when we talked about
imitation learning we talked about if
you had a trajectory and then you tried
to do behavior cloning and learn
mappings from States to actions and how
if you then got that policy and followed
it in the real world you might end up in
parts of the state space where you
didn't have much data and you could have
sort of these escalating errors because
again it could compound once you get in
parts of the state space where you don't
have much data then you're extrapolating
and things can go badly so similarly in
this case if you build a model and you
compute a policy that ends up giving you
two parts of the world where you don't
have very much data and where your model
estimate is poor then again your
resulting value function and your policy
might be bad I guess I'll just mention
one other
advantage I think of with model-based
reinforcement learning is that it can
also be very powerful for transfer
so when Chelsea was here and talking
about metal learning one of the nice
benefits of model-based RL is that if
you learn a dynamics model of the world
then if someone changes the reward
function in plis Utley you can just do
zero shot transfer because you can just
take your learn model of the dynamics
and then your word function you can just
compute a new plan so like if I'm a
robot and I learned how to navigate in
this room and so like now I know like
you know what it's like to turn and what
it's like to go forward etc and before I
was always trying to get to that exit
but now I know a dynamic I know my
dynamics model in general for this room
and then someone says no no I don't want
you go to that exits that one's better
you know clothes or something so go to
that other exit and they tell me the
reward function they say you know user
plus one for that exit now instead of
there then I can just replan with my my
dynamics model so I don't need any more
experience I can get zero shot transfer
so that's can be really useful that's
one of the other reasons why you might
want to just build models of the world
in general and there's some interesting
evidence that when people play Atari
games that they are probably
systematically building models what
happens when I move the iceberg next to
the Polar Bear and because then you can
generalize those models to other
experience okay so how are we going to
write write down our model in this case
we're again just kind of our normal
state action transition dynamics and
reward and we're going to assume that
our model approximately represents our
transition model and our reward model so
we're assuming the Markov assumption
here so we can represent our next date
is just the previous data in action and
the distribution over that and we'll
similarly have that for there for the
reward and we we typically assume things
are conditionally independent like what
we've done before so we just have a
particular dynamics model it's
conditioned on the state an action and a
reward that is conditioned on the
previous state in action and so if we
wanted to do model learning then we have
this supervised learning problem that
we've talked about a little bit before
of you have the state in action and you
want to predict your reward next state
and so we have this regression
problem in this density estimation
problem then you can do it in all sorts
of ways you can I know this means quite
or you can use different forms of losses
and in fact one of the ways we've
recently made progress on off policy
reinforcement learning is by using
different forms of losses then then
standard sort of maximum likelihood
losses but generally here we're gonna
talk about maximum likelihood losses so
we can just do this and of course in the
in the tabular case this is just
counting so if you just have a discrete
set of states and actions you can just
count how many times did I start in this
state in action and go to state one
versus how many times today start in
this state and action go to state two so
you just count those up and then
normalize and in general there's a huge
number of different ways that you can
represent these and I think one of the
ones that I think is particularly
interesting is Bayesian not Bayesian
deep neural networks they've been pretty
hard to tune so far so another process
you know Bayesian D neural networks
um I think one of the reasons those
could be really powerful as they can
explicitly represent uncertainty but so
far they've been pretty hard to train
but I think that there's you know a lot
of really there's some really simple
models we can use as well as some really
rich function approximated for these
models okay so if we're in the table
lookup case we're just averaging counts
so we're just counting as I said this
state action next state tuples dividing
by the number of times we take in that
action in that state and we similarly
just average all the rewards so this
should be the reward scene for the times
that we were in that state took that
action and what was the reward we got on
that time step so let's think about an
example for what that looks like here so
a long time ago we introduced this ABA
example where we have a state that goes
to the state a that goes to action and
state B and then after that it either
goes to a terminal state where I got a
reward of one with 75% probability or it
goes to a terminal state where it gets a
reward of zero with 25% probability
and imagine that we've experienced
something in this world so there's no
actions here you know there's a single
action it's really a Markov reward
process rather than a decision process
but we can get it observations so let's
say we started in state a and then we
got a reward of zero and went to B and
got a zero and then we had a whole set
of times we have six times where we
started a B I've got a reward of 1 and
then we got it started in state B and
got a reward of 0 and now we can
construct a table lookup model from this
and just to refresh our memories so we
talked about the fact that if you do
temporal difference learning in this
problem with a tabular representation
meaning one row for each state so that's
just two states a and B but if you do
infinite replay on this set of
experience then it's equivalent to if
you took this data and estimated or
Markov decision process model with it
and then did planning with that to
evaluate the optimal policy or the
policy that you're using to gather the
data in this case so that was an
interesting equivalence that the TD is
getting exactly the same solution as
what if you compute what's often called
a certainty equivalence model because
you take your data you estimate you take
the empirical s average of that data so
you could say if this was all the data
in the world what would be the model
that you know could be associated with
that with a maximum likelihood estimate
and then you do planning so TD makes
that assumption let's just do a quick
check of memory do Monte Carlo methods
converge to the same solution on this
data so maybe take a minute turn to
somebody next to you and decide whether
or not they do
and why are why not
yeah question how's Anna as an opera
guess okay I think that Monte Carlo
methods will converge to solution would
be minimum MSE supposed to have a li
okay
correct the Monte Carlo methods do not
make an assumption of Markovian so the
they are suitable in cases where the
domain is not Markovian so in this case
they will converge to them at well in
all cases for this policy evaluation
they're gonna converge to the minimum
mean square error yeah question
using that abuse converge for video
piracy what if you're using a different
Lots this is this is this is gonna
converge the minimum MSE not the MLE if
you are using a different boss we didn't
cut you to see yeah let's see you using
like a cougar or Monte Carlo methods
convert straighter I mean depending on
the loss or if you regularized it's a
great question if you regularize um it
may converge to different solutions the
minimum mean squared error depending on
how you regular eyes those loss you use
but in general it will not converge to
the same thing as if you got the maximum
likelihood estimate model and then did
planning with that or policy evaluation
and the key difference is Monte Carlo
was not making a Markovian assumption so
it does does not assume Markov and so in
particular in this case I may have a
guess of what the value of a will be
under the Monte Carlo estimate
there's only one sample of it yeah yeah
yes so there's only four Monte Carlo
here we'll say I am only looking at full
returns that started with this
particular state and there's no
bootstrapping so the only time we saw a
was when the return from a was zero but
you know if the system is really Markoff
that's not a very good solution because
we have all this other evidence that B
is actually normally has a higher value
and we're not able to take advantage of
that
whereas PD does so TB can say well I
know that V of a was there this one time
but in general we think that V of a is
equal to the Rho meter reward plus in
this case there's no discounting so
value of B and I have all this other
other evidence that the value of B is in
this case actually exactly equal to 0.75
because we have six examples of it being
one and two examples of it being zero so
we would have V of B is equal to 0.75
and both Monte Carlo and TV would agree
on that because for if you look at every
time you started and be 75 percent or
you know some of you I percent of time
you got a one the rest of the time you
got a zero so the the value of that is
0.75 so the TV estimate would say also V
of a is equal to 0.75 the TV estimate so
one of the reasons this comes up here
and notice this is a this is not due to
sort of a finite number of back up oh
sorry I'll be careful a finite amount of
use of the data so this is saying if you
sort of run this through TV many many
times and the Monte Carlo estimate is
also getting access to all of the data
it's just saying this is all the data
there is so an alternative would be if
you take this data and you build a model
so now we have a model that says the
probability of going to be given you've
started in a is 1 you always go from it
from A to B in fact you've only ever
seen this once but the one time you saw
it you went to B and we can use this to
try to get simulated data so let me just
well I'll go a couple
or so the idea in this case is that once
you have your simulator you can use it
to simulate samples and then you can
plan using that simulated data now
initially that might sound like why
would you do that because you had your
previous data maybe you could have
directly you know put it through a model
free based approach like why would you
first build a model and then generate
data from it but we'll see an example
right now from that sort of a B example
of why that might be beneficial so
you're what we can do is we can get this
we can get the maximum likelihood
estimate of the model or other estimates
you might want to use and then you can
sample from it so in that example we
just had here our estimated transition
model is that whenever we ran a we go to
B so when I'm in a I can sample and I
will go to B and that generates me a
fake data point and I could do this a
whole bunch of times we get lots of fake
data
now this fake data may or may not look
like what the real world does it depends
how good my model is but it's certainly
data I can train with and and we'll see
a minute a second why that's beneficial
okay so if we go back to here this is
the real experience on the left so on
the left hand side we had all this real
experience and then what we did is we
built a model from that and then we
could sample from it so we could have
experience that looks very similar to
the data that we've actually seen but we
could also have experience like this now
why could we have that because we now
have a simulator and are in our
simulated in our model we've seen cases
where we started in a and we went to B
and in our model there have been other
times where we've started in B and we've
got a one so essentially we can kind of
chain that experience together and
simulate something that we never
observed in the real world and we're
leveraging the fact here that it's
Markov so if the domain isn't really
Markov we could end up getting data that
looks very very different than what you
could ever get in the real world but if
it's Markov then and it may still be an
approximate model because we only had a
limit
out of data trainer model but now we can
start to see conjunctions of states and
actions but we maybe never saw in our
data model as we sample well okay could
you update your mother just simple you
could but right now we're just sampling
from our models so there's this is not
real-world experience so that could lead
to confirmation bias because it's like
your model is giving you data and if you
treat that as real data and put that
back into your model it's not from the
real world so you could end up sort of
being overly confident in I because
you're generating fake data and then
treaty is if it's real in our sample
experience and it's like relative to how
much training do you thought the
building model okay so how would be how
do we know how competent to be and in
general this is the issue of your models
are gonna be pretty bad sometimes if you
have limited amounts of data so some of
the techniques we talked about for
exploration where we could to drive
these confidence intervals over how good
the bottles are they up live here as
well so if you only have a little bit of
data you can use things like hop ting to
say oh sure am I about this reward model
for example for most of us say we're not
going to talk about that that much but
you can use that information to try to
quantify how uncertain should you be and
how would that error kind of propagate
yeah
so I guess I'm trying to like
conceptually think about the next step
is that we are we're building this model
we're gonna use a method to learn some
sort of a policy or some sort of like
way to act in the way of work if we have
the model can't you just use the model
when you're acting and just basically
run our stake through the model and get
maybe like a distribution and just take
the maximum action and the action that
maximizes our anymore so I guess once
you have the model you could use it in
lots of different ways to do planning so
one is you could do if it's a small case
like here it's a table so you could use
value iteration and solve this exactly
there's no reason to simulate data but
when you start to think about doing like
Atari or other really high dimensional
problems the planning problem alone is
super expensive and so you might still
want to do model free methods for your
planning with your simulated data
and one of the reasons you might want to
do that is because we've we talked about
different ways in Q learning to be more
sample efficient like you have a replay
buffer and you can do that the sonic
replay but another alternative is you
just generate a lot of data from your
simulated model and then you replay over
that a ton of times and so that's
another way to kind of make more use out
of your data yeah question the mic if
you don't want to make the market
assumption can you still do the same but
condition on the past early yeah what if
you don't want to make the Markov
assumption yes you and can you condition
on the past you absolutely can that
means you would build models that are
full function of the history the problem
with that is you don't have very much
data so you have to if you want a
condition on the entire history as
essentially your state you're always
fine in terms of the Markov assumption
but you'll just have really really
little data to estimate the transition
models particularly as the horizon goes
on so it's often a trade-off like do you
want to have better models well depends
on your domain maybe it's really markov
if it's not really Markov do you want a
better models with very little data so
general this sort of gets to the
function approximation error versus the
sample estimation error you can have
error due to the fact that you don't
have much data or you can have error due
to the fact that your function
approximation is wrong and often you're
going to want to trade-off between those
two so so this example you know you can
end up getting this sampled experience
that looks different than anything
you've seen in reality and then in in
this case if you now run Monte Carlo on
the new data you may you can get
something that looks very similar if
you've done TD on the original data so
basically instead of taking our real
experience and then doing Monte Carlo
using that for policy evaluation an
alternative is to say we really think
that this is a Markov system let's
simulate a bunch of data and then you
could run Monte Carlo learning on this
or TD learning on it and you would get
probably the same answer so this is you
know in contrast to what magic Harlow
would have converged to before which was
V of a is equal to 0 and B of B is equal
to 0.75 now again you might say okay but
do I really want to do this like if I if
I really didn't think the system was
Markov I wouldn't have run
Monte Carlo on my fake data either but I
think this illustrates what you couldn't
do once you have the sampling and just
shows that allows you to make all sorts
of choices so maybe there you want to
have sort of a two-step Markov process
or you want to do different make
different assumptions in your model and
then after that you want to do a lot of
planning with it so that just allows you
to first take your data compute a model
and then you can decide how you're going
to use that to try to do planning and
we'll see a particular way to do that
shortly now as you guys were just asking
me about if we have a bad model then
we're gonna compute a suboptimal policy
in general you know we might be
incredibly lucky because ultimately for
decisions we only need to decide whether
you know B of s a 1 is greater than V of
s a 2 so ultimately we're gonna be
making comparison pairwise comparison
decisions so you might be have a really
bad model and still end up with a good
policy but in general if your models bad
and you do planning in general your
policy is also going to be suboptimal
and so one approach if the model is
wrong is to do model free reinforcement
learning on the original data so not to
do model-based planning it's not clear
that always solves the issue so it
depends why your model is wrong if your
model is wrong because you pick the
wrong parametric class or because the
system is not Markov they're doing Q
learning that's not gonna solve your
problem because Q learning also assumes
the world is Markov so model free you
know it depends on why you know why is
it wrong depends on why whether or not
this helps another is to reason
explicitly about your model uncertainty
and this is goes back to the exploration
exploitation
now again this only deals with a
particular form of wrongness it deals
with the fact that you might have
sampling estimation error but it's still
making the basic assumption that your
model class is correct so for example if
you're modeling in the world as a
multinomial distribution and you want
very much data then your prior metric
estimates will be off
but if the world really isn't a
multinomial then all that's rather so
it's always good to know sort of what
assumptions we're making in our
algorithms and then what's through forms
of uncertainty
we're accounting for now I guess I'll
just say one other thing which is a
little bit subtle which I find super
interesting which is if you have a
really good model it is I generally say
or if you have a perfect model and
perfect estimate of the parameters that
is sufficient to make good decisions if
you are trying to train your model and
you have a restricted amount of data or
restricted sort of expressivity of your
model then a model that has higher
predictive accuracy can in fact be worse
when you use it to make decisions and
the intuition I like to think of is this
we discovered this a few years ago
others have discovered it - we were
thinking about it for an intelligent
tutoring system the the challenge is
let's imagine that you have like a
really complicated state space say
you're trying to model what a kitchen
looks like when someone's making tea and
there's all sorts of features you know
like there's steam maybe there's a
sunset outside oh and there's also the
temperature of the water and in order to
make tea you need the water to be over
100 degrees and in fact that's the only
feature you need to pay attention to in
order to successfully make tea but if
you're trying to just do build a model
of the world you're trying to model the
sunset you're trying to model the steam
etc and there could be a huge number of
features that you're trying to capture
in your sort of you know maybe slightly
impoverished neural network and so if
you just try to fit the best maximum
likelihood estimate model it might not
be the one that captures the features
that you need to make decisions and so
models that look better in terms of
predictive accuracy may not always be
better in terms of decision making that
was this issue we encountered a few
years ago and I think it just
illustrates why the models that we need
to build when we want to make decisions
are not necessarily the same models we
need for predictive accuracy so it's
important we're possible to know which
of your features do you care about in
terms of utility and value okay so let's
talk a little bit about simulation based
search who here's seen for word search
before and one of their classes okay
number of people but not everybody and
so forward search algorithms
what we're gonna talk about now is
different ways instead of doing two
learning on our simulated data okay
we've got a model what's another way we
can use it to try to make decisions one
way is to do forward search so how does
forward search work the idea in forward
search is that we are gonna think about
all the actions we could take so let's
say here we just have two actions you
want to Nate you and then we're gonna
think about all the possible next States
we might get to so let's say it's a
fairly small world so we just have s1
and s2 so in this current state I could
either take action 1 or action - and
after I take those actions
I could either transition to state 1 or
state 2 and then after I get to whatever
I state state I get to I again could
make a decision a 1 or a 2 because
that's my action space here and then
after I take that action
I again might transition or maybe
sometimes I terminate so this is a
terminal state maybe my robot falls off
or falls down or things like that or
maybe else I go to another state and I
can think of sort of like these
branching set of futures and I can roll
them out as much as I want to let's say
I want to think about the next H steps
for example and then I halt and once I
have that I can use that information and
the my sort of reward well let me just
say one more thing which is as I do
these sort of like simulated futures I
can think about what the reward would I
get under these different futures
because right now I'm assuming I have a
model so this is given a model so I can
think about if I took this state as T
and took action hu what reward would I
get and then down here I can think about
if I got what reward I would get an S 2
a 2 so I can think of sort of generating
different futures and then summing up
the rewards or getting a series of
reward along any of those different
paths and then in order to figure out
the value of these different sort of
actions or the best action I should take
what I can do is I can take a max over
actions and I can take an expectation
over States
and I always know how to take that
expectation because I'm assuming I have
a model so I can always think about what
would be the probability of me getting
to that particular state given my parent
action and the state I'm coming from so
what happens in this case is is I roll
out all these potential features up
until a certain depth in the case of go
or something like that it would be until
you win the game or lose the game and
then I want to back up so you can think
of this as sort of doing a not very
efficient form of dynamic programming
because why is it not so efficient
because there might be many states in
here which are identical and I'm not I'm
not
aliasing those or I'm not treating them
as identical I'm saying I'm gonna
separately think about for each of those
states I would reach what would be the
future reward I would get from that
state under different sequences its
actions and resulting states and then if
I want to figure out how to act I go
from my leaves and I take a max over all
that so let's say in this case I just we
do it for like a simple small one this
is a1 a2 now let's say at that point I
terminate so I got like R of sa1 sa-2 so
anytime I have a structure that looks
like that what I do is I take at max and
the reward here is equal to whichever of
those was bigger let's imagine that it
was a tree that was bigger so if I want
to compute I basically roll all of these
out computing like getting a sample of
the reward and the next state as I go
all the way out and then to to get the
value at the root whenever I see two up
to like a series of action nodes I take
a max over all of them which is just
like in our bellman back up we're taking
a max over the action that allows us to
have the best future rewards and then
whenever I get two states I'll do
another one here so let's say now I have
two states s1 and s2 and one of them has
this value s1 and this one has value s2
and I want to figure out for this action
but what my new value is then this is
going to be equal to the probability
the best one given say I came from s 0 s
0 a1 times B of s 1 plus probability of
s 2 s is 0 a1 times V of s this is
exactly like when we do a bellman back
up that we think about all the next
dates I could get to under the current
action and current state times the value
of each of those that make sense so we
construct this tree out and then in
order to can beat the value we do one of
two operations for either we take the
max over the actions if it's a an action
notes or we take an expectation so these
are called is expecting max trees some
of you guys might have seen these before
in AI sometimes people often talk about
minimax trees so if you're playing game
theory where the other agent gets to try
to minimize your value and you get to
maximize it
this is very similar except for we're
doing an expectation over next States
and then max over actions and it's
exactly like dynamic program but more
inefficient but we're gonna see why we
would want to do that in a second
so many questions about this ok all
right so this is all and the way we do
this is that we have to have a model
because if we don't have a model right
now we can't compute this expecting max
exact exactly because we're using that
we know like we're only expanding two
states here and where we in order to
figure us out how much weight we want to
put on each of those two states we need
to know the probability of getting to
each of them okay so that's where we're
using the model here and we're using the
model to get the rewards so simulation
based search is similar except for we're
just gonna simulate out with a model
we're not going to compute all of these
sort of exponentially growing number of
futures instead we're just gonna say I'm
gonna start here and I have a model and
I each have some policy here but let's
say I have a policy PI and then I just
use that so I look at my policy for the
current state and it tells me something
to do so I followed that action and then
I go into my model and I sample an S
Prime
so I look at my model and I say what
would be the next state given that I was
in this particular state and took that
action and I just simulate one next
state
this is just like how we could have
simulated data from our models before so
let's say that got me to here which was
state s 1 and then I look up again I
look up in my policy and I say what is
the policy for s 1 would say that's a 2
and then I'll sit then I follow it down
to here they're just simulate out a
trajectory just following my policy
simulating it out as I go until it
terminates and that gives me 1 return of
how good that policy is so in these sort
of cases we can just simulate complete
trajectories with the model and once we
have those you could do something like
model free RL over those simulated
trajectories which either could be Monte
Carlo or it could be something like TV
learning so if we think of this as sort
of doing like in order to do that
simulation we need some sort of policy
you have to have some way to pick
actions in our sort of simulated world
when we think about being in the state
and taking an action how do we know what
action to take we follow our current
simulation policy so let's say we wanted
to do effectively one step of policy
improvement so you have a policy you
have your model and then you start off
in a state and for each of the possible
actions you simulate out trajectories so
this is like doing Monte Carlo rollouts
so I started my state so this is let's
say I'm really in a state st and I would
need to figure out what to do next so I
started that state st and then in my
head before I take an action in the real
world I think about all the actions I
could take and then I just do rollouts
from each of them under a behavior
policy PI then I pick the max over those
so I'm really in state st and then in my
brain I think about doing a 1 and then I
do lots of rollouts from that under my
policy PI and then I do a 2 and do lots
of rollouts I love that a 3 this is all
in my head and that basically gives me
you know an estimate of Q sta-1
under pi
so if I was to take this action then
follow-up I what would bring my
estimated cube unction and I do that for
each of the actions and then I can take
a max so this is sort of like doing one
set of policy improvement because this
is gonna depend on whatever my
simulation policy is that make sense so
have some existing simulation policy I
haven't told you how we get it and then
we use it to simulate out experience
okay so the question is whether or not
we can actually do better than one step
of policy improvement feels like how do
we get these simulation policies like
okay if we had a simulation policy it
was good we could do this one step but
how could we do this in a more general
setting well the idea is that if you
have this model you could actually
compute the optimal values by doing this
expecting max tree so like I was in the
state st and instead of just thinking
about so remember in simulation based
search we're just gonna follow out one
trajectory but the in the expecting max
tree we can think of well what if I did
a 1 or a 2 and after that whether I went
to s1 or s2 and then what action should
I do there and I can think of basically
trying to compute the optimal Q function
under my approximate model for the
current state okay the problem with that
is that this tree gets really big so in
general the size of the tree is gonna
scale at least with s times a to the H
if H is the horizon because each step
this is why it's not as efficient at
dynamic programming idea at each step
you're going to think about all the
possible next States and then all the
possible next actions and so this tree
is growing exponentially with the
horizon and if you think of something
like alphago that are playing you know
for a number of time steps before
someone wins or loses this H might be
somewhere between 50 to 200 so if you
have anything larger than an extremely
small States base like 1 then this is
not gonna be not gonna be feasible so
the idea would soar Monte Carlo tree
search is that ok we'd like to do better
on we'd in any case we need some sort of
simulation policy if we're gonna do this
at all and we can't be as
computationally intractable as foolish
back t max so how do we do something in
between so so the idea with Monte Carlo
tree search is to try to kind of get the
best of both worlds where what we would
really like is the expect Emax tree
where we think about all possible
futures and take a max over those but
instead we need to do that in a little
bit more computationally tractable way
and why might that be possible
well let's think about this let's if we
have our initial starting state let's
say this is our general tree it's going
all these ups some of these potential
ways of acting might be really really
bad so some of these it might be clear
very early like with very little amounts
of data that or very little amounts of
rollouts that in fact these are ways you
would never want to play go because
you're gonna immediately lose and so
then you don't need to bother sort of
continuing to spend a lot of
computational effort fleshing out that
tree when something else might look much
better so that's kind of the intuition
here is that what we're gonna do is
we're gonna get us construct a partial
search tree so we're gonna start at the
current state and we can sample actions
in next state just like in simulation
based search so maybe we first sample a
1 and then we sample s1 again and then
we sample a 2 so we start off when we
kind of the very first round it looks
exactly like simulation based search but
the idea is that then we can do this
multiple times and slowly fill out the
tree so maybe next time we happen to
sample a 2 and then maybe we sample s 2
and then sample a 1 and so you can think
of slowly filling in this expecting max
tree and in the limit you will fill in
the entire expecting max tree
it's just that in practice you almost
never will because it's computationally
intractable so what we're gonna do is do
this and we'll do this for sort of a
number of simulation episodes each
simulation episode can be thought of as
you start at the root this is the root
node current state you're early at and
then you roll out until you reach a
terminal state or a horizon age and then
you go back to the start State and you
again make another trajectory and when
you're done with all of this you can do
the same thing you would do and expect
Emax in that you're always going to take
a max over actions and an X back
tation overstates but you only will have
filled in part of the tree so part of
the tree might be missing so in order to
do this there's two key aspects one is
what do you do in parts of the tree we
already have some data so like if you
already have tried both actions in a
state which action should you pick again
and then what should you do when you
reach like a node where there's nothing
else there or like there's only been one
thing tried so far so this is often
called the the tree policy in the
rollout policy the rollout policy is for
when you get to a node where you you
know you've only tried one thing or
there's no more data who you've never
been there before so for example maybe
you sample a state that you've never
reached before and so that's now a new
node and from then on you do a rollout
policy will show an example of this in a
second and then the idea is when we're
thinking about computing the Q function
we're just gonna average over all
rewards that are received from that node
onwards this should seem a little bit
weird
because we're not talking about maxes
anymore we're not talking about doing
considering explicitly like the
expectation over states in our in a
formal way we're just gonna average this
the reason why this is okay is because
we're gonna sort of sample actions in a
way such that over time we're going to
sample actions that look better much
more and so we expect that eventually
the distribution of data is gonna
converge to the true Q is the difference
between this and the simulation before
it's different kind of averaging and
moving parts because it seemed before we
were also doing a bunch of rollouts and
then reminding those so that part is
still the same yes we're still gonna be
sort of doing a bunch of simulation so
we're gonna be averaging them the
question is what is the policy we're
using to do the the rollouts is
generally going to be changing for each
rollout it said I've been identical
across all rollouts and then the way
we're gonna average them is also
different and the really the key part I
think is that instead of using like when
I said for simple Monte Carlos
that assumes that you fix a policy and
get a whole bunch of Burrell outs from
that policy just starting with different
initial actions but then always
following it when you do Monte Carlos
research and you also do sake a rollouts
generally the policy will be different
for each of the K rollouts and that's on
purpose so that you can hopefully get to
a better policy
okay so again just a and just to step
back again what are you know what's the
whole loop of happening here so what's
happening in this case is like you have
your agent here's our robot and it's
trying to figure out an action to take
and then the real world gives back at s
Prime and an R Prime
and then what we're talking about right
now is everything it needs to do in its
head like all these rollouts in order to
decide the next action to take so it's
going to do a whole bunch of planning
before it takes its next action general
it may then throw that whole tree away
and then the world's going to give it
and you stated a new reward and that's
screwed and to do this whole process
together again so the key thing is that
we need to decide what action to take
next and we want to do so in a way that
we're gonna get the best expected value
given the information we have so far now
in general in Monte Carlo tree search
you might also have another step here
where you might compute Aminu model so
if you're doing this online you might
take your most recent data retrain your
model given that model rerun Monte Carlo
tree search and now decide what you're
gonna do on the next time step all right
so the key thing is really this tree
policy and roll out both of them make a
difference the rollout often is done
randomly at least in the most basic
vanilla version there's tons of
extensions for it for this um the key
part is the tree policy so one of the
really common ways to do this is called
upper confidence tree search and this
relates to what we were talking about
over the last few weeks with exploration
so the idea is is that when we're
rolling out so let's say we're in st and
we're using our simulated models to
think about the next actions and states
we would be in
so let's say I get to state 1 and at
this point I wanted let's say I've taken
a 1 and a 2 in the past and I've ended
up with you know I've done lots of
rollouts from these and a number of
rollouts from here and let's say 3 times
I got let's say I won the game so three
ones and I got 1 1 and 1 0 ok so the key
is what what action should I take next
time I encounter s1 when I'm doing my
rollout and the idea is to be optimistic
with respect to the data you have so far
so essentially we're going to treat this
as a bandit think of each decision point
as its own bandit its own independent
bandit and say well if I've taken all
the actions I could for my current state
what is my average reward I've got from
each of those actions under any rollout
that I've taken from that particular
node in the graph and action and how
many times did I take it so you can get
your empirical average for that state 1
in the in the graph a 1 plus a discount
factor that often looks like the number
of times you've been in that particular
node ok this is really a node in the
graph this is also for that node so we
think about sort of every time I've been
in that node what and taken that
particular action what's the average
Ward I've gotten plus how many times
have I done that and it just allows you
to be uses optimism again it says well
when I've reached different parts of the
graph before using my simulated model
what things look good I'm gonna focus on
making sure that that's the part of the
tree that I flush out more because
that's the one where I think I'm gonna
get likely reach policies that have
higher value and so hopefully that's
gonna mean that I have need less
computation in order to compute a good
policy does that make sense so like if
you had an Oracle that could tell you
what the optimal policy was then you
would only need to fill in that part of
the tree and what we're using here is
we're saying well given the data we've
seen so far can we kind of only you know
focus on the parts of the tree that seem
like they're going to be the ones that
when we take our max over actions are
gonna be the ones that we end up
propagating the values back up to the
root
all right so we maintain an upper
competence found over the reward of each
are using sort of exactly the same thing
as what we've done before
and we're treating each of the nodes so
each state node as a separate bandit and
so that means essentially that you know
the next time we reach that same node in
the tree we might do something different
because the counts will change treaty
could use whether this is kind of like
TV engine sense that if you reward for
the bandit problem' the value of that of
the stators if the make the state action
pair or is it the reward for just that
transition it's a great question so for
this bandit we're gonna treat it as um
essentially the full roll out from that
node because that's what we're averaging
over and we're captain doing counts it's
not like TD in the sense that we're
doing this per node so as I mentioned
before you know you might have s1 a1 up
here in this part of the graph and s1
a-1 appear over here and we're not
combining their counts we're treating
every node as if it's totally distinct
even though often the model we'll be
using to simulate will be mark off but
inside of the treat you can do it's
mostly that it becomes a lot more
complicated for implementation if you
want to basically treat it as a graph
instead of it the tree now I think the
other point that you're bringing that
we'll come back to in a second which is
is this a good idea is is what what are
the limitations of the bandit setting so
we'll come back to them in a second all
right so let's talk about this in the
context of go for those of you that
haven't played go or aren't too familiar
with it it's at least 2500 years old
it's considered the classic hardest
board game and it's been known as a
grand challenge task in AI for a very
long period of time just to remind
ourselves this is not involving
decision-making in a case where the
dynamics and reward model are unknown
but the rules of go are known the reward
structure is known but it's an
incredibly large search space so if we
think about the combinatorics that the
number of possible boards that you can
see it's it's extremely large so
just briefly there's two different types
of stones most people probably know this
I and typically its played on a 19 by 19
board though people have also thought
about it you know some people play on
smaller boards and you want to capture
the most territory and it's a finite
game because there's a finite number of
places to put stones on the board so
it's a finite horizon I'm gonna go
through this part sort of briefly
there's different ways to write down you
can write down the reward function for
this game in terms of I you know
different you could do different
features the simplest one is just to
look at whether or not white wins or
black wins on the game and in that case
it's a very sparse reward signal and you
only get reward at the very end so you
just have to play out all the way and
see which game which wish for someone
and then your value function is
essentially what's the expected
probability of you winning in the
current state so how does this work if
we do Monte Carlo evaluation so let's
imagine this is your current board and
you have a particular policy then you
play out against stationary opponent is
normally assumed but then at the end you
see your outcome so maybe you won twice
and you lost twice and so then the value
for this current start state is a half
so how would we do want to call it
research in this case so you start off
and you have one single start state so
at this point you haven't simulated any
part of the tree so we've never taken
any action so you just sample randomly
so maybe you take a 1 and then you
follow your default policy and this is
often random though for things like
alphago you often want much better
policies but you can just use a random
policy no just take random actions and
get to next States and you do this until
the end and you see you either win or
lose now in this case it's a two-player
game so we do a minimax tree instead of
expect Emacs but the basic ideas are
exactly the same so that's my first roll
out I'm gonna do lots of these roll outs
before I figure out how I'm gonna
actually place my piece ok so the next
time this is my second roll out since
just
second roll out of my head I say okay
well last time you know I took this
action so now I have my default policy
so this time I'm gonna take the other
action generally you want to fill in all
try all the actions at least once from a
current note now the particular order in
which you try actions can make a big
difference and early on there was
significant savings by putting in action
heuristics of what order to try actions
in right now let's just imagine you have
to try all actions equally so in this
case now you take the other action and
then after that you've never tried
anything from that action so you just
drew a roll out again just actually
randomly okay and then you repeat this
so now when you get to here so let's say
I've tried this before so now when I get
to this note I have to pick I have to do
a max maybe using my UCT so I look at
what was the reward for this one and
their word for this one plus you know
something about the counts alright this
is cute I make it clearer and so I pick
whichever action happened to have looked
better in the rollouts I've done print
from so far and then I'm gonna focus on
expanding that part of the tree and you
keep doing this and you're gonna slowly
sort of build out the tree and you do
this until your computational budget
expires and then you go to the bottom of
the tree and you go all the way back up
where for each of the action nodes
you're taking the max in each of the
state nodes you're doing the neck
spectator you doing a in this case
minimax opponent in my name is like a
stationary unknown okay so one of the
other really big insights to why people
got go to work is self play so typically
in this you would use the current agent
as the opponent so I take whatever
policy I just computed for for the other
particulars imagine that like I kept
that tree so it already knows what it's
gonna do so at each point I would look
at I would have the other agent tell me
what action it would do in that state
but one of the really so I think self
play was incredibly important insight
for this and why is it so important
because
if I play against a grandmaster and go I
get no reward for a really long period
of time and that's an incredibly hard
thing for an agent to learn from because
there's no other reward signal and so
basically you're just playing these tons
and tons and tons of games and like
there's just no signal for a really
really long time and so you need some
sort of signal so you can start to
bootstrap and actually get to a good
policy if I play against me five five
minutes ago I'm probably gonna beat them
and or at least half the time maybe I'll
beat them and so that allows because you
can have two players that are both bad
and one of them is gonna win and one of
them is gonna lose and you start to get
signal and so this self play idea has
been hugely helpful in the context of
games like two-player games because it
can mean that you can start to get some
rewards signal about what things are
successful or not and then it's both
felt like it's both gives you helps with
a special word problem and it gives you
a curriculum because you're always kind
of only playing in an environment that's
a little bit more difficult than perhaps
what you can challenge and I actually
think it would be really really cool if
we could figure out how to take the same
ideas to a lot of other domains like if
there are other ways to essentially make
self play for things like medicine or
customer relations or things like that
it would be really great because it's
often really hard to get this sort of
rewards signal you want and that's one
of the really nice things here
so play well then we get stuck and some
local Hema absolutely yeah but it's only
how is it okay you're always tried to
max so it's a little bit like policy
improvement you're always trying to do a
little bit better you're still trying to
win so it's possible you could get stuck
in a case where you're both just you
know winning half the time but then
there should be something you can
exploit and if there's something new can
exploit if you do enough planning you
should be able to identify it
did you imagine that there would be just
a transition point where you might get
added benefit from transitioning to a
more expert player to play against
versus yourself the utility kind of
starts slowly and he's into it but then
you might actually do learn it faster by
playing against somebody harder yeah
like you know would you also always want
to kind of do just like sell play
against you know yourself five minutes
ago or maybe at some point you it would
be more efficient to go at someone
harder I think it's a great question I
think probably that's the case like
probably there would be cases where you
could do bigger curriculum jumps and
that might accelerate learning but I
think it's a tricky sweet spot there if
like you still need to have enough
reward signal to bootstrap from
absolutely all right so you know the
benefits of doing this is it becomes
this highly selective best first search
because you're sort of constructing part
of the tree but you're constructing it
in a very specific way and the goal is
that you should be way more sample
efficient than doing expect Emax and
making the whole tree but you're gonna
be much better than doing just a single
step of policy improvement with some
fixed you know simulation based policy
and it's also you know paralyze about
any time anytime in the sense that like
whether you have one minute or you have
three hours to compute the next action
and you know three hours could be very
realistic if it's something like you
know a customer recommendation article
or thing that's gonna make or maybe
you're gonna make one decision per day
and so you could run it overnight for
eight hours and then compute that one
decision so it allows you to take
advantage of the computation you have
but then always provide an answer no
matter how quickly you need to do that
because you just do less we'll else I'm
gonna skip this for now I just want to
mention briefly and I think it was
question it's a little weird that we can
do bandits at each of the nodes and and
intuitively the reason it's a little bit
weird is because in bandits why do we do
optimism under uncertainty we do it
because we're actually incurring the
pain of making bad decisions and so the
idea with Optimas onder and certainty is
that either you really do get high
reward or you learn something the weird
thing about doing that for planning is
that we're not suffering if we make bad
decisions in our head essentially we're
just trying to figure out what actions
can I take as quickly as possible in
terms of like value of
so that I know what the right action is
taken the route and so it doesn't
actually matter if I simulate out bad
actions if it allows me to get a better
decision of the route we just give a
really quick example of where that could
be different so if you have something
like this let's say this is the
potential value of Q okay this is the
value of a1 and this is the value of a2
and this is our uncertainty well if
you're being optimistic you're always
gonna select this because it's got a
higher value but if you want to be
really confident that a 1 is better you
should select a2 because likely when you
do that you're gonna update your
confidence intervals and now you're
gonna be totally sure that a1 is best
but this approach won't do that because
it's it's a no I'm gonna suffer the cost
in my head of taking the wrong action so
I'm gonna take a1 but if ultimately you
just need to know what the right action
is to do then sometimes in terms of
computation you should take a 2 because
now your confidence intervals will
likely separate you don't need to do any
more computation so it's not clear that
the bandits at each node is the optimal
thing to do but it's pretty efficient
all right so that's basically all we I'm
gonna say about go there's some really
beautiful papers about this including
the new recent extensions and they have
applications to chess as well as you
know a number of other games which I
think are really there they're amazing
results so I highly encourage you to
look at some of those papers let me just
briefly talk about sort of popping back
up to the end of the course because it's
the last lecture all right so I just
wanted to sort of refresh on you know
what were the goals of the course um as
we end and some of these you guys had a
chance to practice on on Monday but I
just sort of wanted to say what I think
of is kind of the key things that I hope
you got out of it so the one I sort of
what is the key features of RL versus
everything else
both AI and supervised learning and to
me is that really this kiya issue of the
agents being off to gather their own
data and make decisions in the world and
so it's the sensor data that's very
different than the iid assumption for
supervised learning and it's also very
different from planning because you are
reliant on the data you get about the
world in order to make decisions
this is probably the second thing is
probably the thing that for many of you
might end up being the most useful which
is just how do you figure out given a
problem whether you should even write it
down as an RL problem and how to
formulate it we had you practiced this a
little bit on Monday and also it's a
chance to think about this a lot in some
of your projects but I think this is
often one of the really hard parts it
has huge implications for how easy or
hard it is to solve the problem and it's
often unclear there's lots of ways to
write down the state space of describing
a patient or describing a student or
describing a customer and it in some
ways goes back to this issue of function
approximation versus sample efficiency I
treat all customers the say might have a
lot of data it's probably pretty bad
model so there's a lot of different
trade-offs that come up in these cases
and I'm sure all of you guys will think
about interesting exciting new ways to
address that and then the other three
things where you know to be very
familiar with the number of common RL
algorithms which you guys have
implemented a lot to understand how we
should even decide if an RL algorithm is
good whether it's empirically compute
you know in terms of its computational
complexity or things like how much data
it takes or its performance guarantees
and to understand this exploration
exploitation challenge which really is
quite unique to RL it doesn't come up
and planning doesn't come up in ml and
again it's this critical issue of like
how do you gather data quickly in order
to make good decisions if you want to
learn more about reinforcement learning
there's a bunch of other classes
particularly micro Kaka and effort has
some really nice ones and also Ben Van
Roy does some nice ones particularly
looking at some of the more theoretical
aspects of it and then I do an advanced
survey of it where we do current topics
and it's a project-based class um and
I'll just I guess I'll two more things
one is that I think you know we see some
really amazing results go is one example
and we're seen starting to see some
really exciting results in robotics but
I think we are missing most of us do not
have RL on our phone yet in the way that
we have face recognition on our phone
and so I think that the potential of
using these types of ideas for a lot of
other types of applications is still
enormous and so if you go off and you do
some of that I would love to hear back
about it in my lab we think a lot about
these other forms of applications and I
think another really critical aspect of
this is thinking about when we do these
RL
agents how do we do it in sort of safe
fair and accountable ways because
typically these systems are going to be
part of you know a human the loop system
and so allowing the agents to sort of
expose their their reasoning and expose
their limitations will be critical so
the final thing is that it's really
helpful to get you guys this feedback it
allows us to improve the class for
future years either to make sure we
continue to do things that you found
helpful or that we stopped doing things
that you didn't find helpful so I'd
really appreciate it we could take about
ten minutes now to go through the course
evaluations and just feed it let us know
what helps you learn what things we
could do even better next year Thanks